why should you have to give up something
that you or your forefathers work for
that is my Heritage that's Fay pton the
government wants to sees her home in
Ocean Springs Mississippi even though
she's done nothing wrong this year the
city quietly deemed her house and
several other properties slums allowing
officials to take their homes and
demolish them for economic development
the kicker she didn't know about the
plan until it was too late to challenge
it under Mississippi Law people like Fay
only have 10 days to appeal she didn't
find out about the government's decision
until 4 months later so how is the
government doing this imminent domain
allows the state to take someone's
property as long as they provide just
compensation sometimes governments take
property for important utility projects
but it's often for political pet
projects Ocean Springs plan includes
tourist attractions just recently the
San Antonio city council took possession
of a man's private business so they can
expand the Alamo grounds and earlier
this year Tennessee was busy seizing
land from black Farmers so Ford can
build an electric vehicle Factory and
your property could be next